we thought it might be fun we do get a
lot of questions about you sona
specifically and we don't want to answer
them for you
okay
so we thought maybe you could come on
and help us answer some of the listener
questions we get sure i'd love to answer
sure yes thanks yeah i can't promise
it'll this will be good i mean
but it'll be i'll be talking yeah
define good
okay well i have a question for you yeah
uh from orocos 28
what other jobs did you have before
working with conan and then what was
your interview process like oh my god i
had a lot of jobs i've been working
since i was 16. i had my first job was
at burger king yay then i worked at a
watch store in the mall called tick time
then
i was a
peer tutor in college then i worked for
i did a work study program because i was
a financial aid at usc and so i worked
in the
college of letters arts and sciences
then i worked at hollywood bowl for a
summer and i got fired yeah uh-oh why'd
you get fired yeah j you just tell us so
you know the hollywood bowl season is
short it's just the summer and so for i
i was like i'm gonna need two weeks off
because i was gonna go to australia and
that was a lot to ask oh
two of three weeks yeah
but they liked me so they're like yeah
we'll keep your job you go to australia
you come back it's you know it was a big
ask but they did it
and then when they when i came back i
just didn't want to do the job anymore i
just you'd been changed by your trip i
hated it you had to park under the 101
overpass and you had to frogger it over
to the hollywood bowl right in the like
highland traffic and you would have to
go at like two and stay till 11. so all
these days during the summer were gone
having to go to work at 2pm no wonder
you quit i hated it i i loved the job i
hated the hours and i was so young i was
just like and so i just stopped
showing up oh okay so you kind of quit
essentially yeah but then i i was like
you know when you want to break up with
someone but you don't want to break up
with them so you just become really bad
and then you make it so that they break
up with you that's what i did in the
hollywood bowl yeah yeah so i it was
labor day weekend it was like one of
their busiest weekends and i was like i
can't come in and they're like
all right okay i think your season's
done they called me and they were like
this is this is it and i felt terrible
but then you felt great and then i felt
great then i you know was in palm
springs and i just went into the pool
what a dick i know that's really shitty
then i was a page at nbc and then i
worked in the uh events and operations
department and then i got my job at
conant so
yeah and then there were other jobs
sprinkled in here and there there were
like you know two months here or three
months here wow yeah that's a impressive
work history resume yeah i come from an
immigrant family we worked right just
consistently from the moment you can
although i don't know anyone who has a
more diverse
resume than you sweeney i think you win
i think you have the most diverse that's
true work resume mailman
lawyer yeah head writer i have to say
being a mailman that was my summer job
in college that was my favorite job what
a great job that was back when people
like actually wanted to get mail oh so i
i i think now it would be depressing but
back then you get it you get your steps
in i think that part oh my god it was 10
miles a day yeah your calves were
probably jacked did you drive one of the
cars or you were a horse oh yeah the
cute little car it's called a quarter
ton jeep
i drove that and you're on the other
side of the road the steering wheel's on
the left i mean on the right side that's
right because you have to put mail in
the mailboxes into the box and i learned
to really hate dogs delivering mail
that's all true well every time i bring
in my dog everyone's fawning over my dog
you hate my dog well but you have a good
reason for it i mean that makes sense to
me because
dogs are real [ __ ] to mailmen yeah
do you remember like right before we
left warner brothers that you brought
your dog in yes and i i said oh god
there's a rat someone we have rats in
the building and kramer was there yeah
and i told him kramer we have we have a
rat problem and i thought he knew i was
referring to your dog and he actually
went
he called warner brothers right he
called warner brothers an exterminator
came in well later that day i was in the
hallway and he was walking down with a
guy in
uniform and they're like i don't know
the third floor seems clear and i'm like
what
i was just like what are you guys doing
he's like he's like you reported the
rats
we're sweeping the building
oh my god yeah oh i love that story
jesus good for kramer well and then sona
there was a second part to this question
which was what was the interview process
like oh just yeah okay so my first
interview was with so i applied to be a
pa because i just wanted a job on the
show cool and this was the tonight show
or tonight's show yeah no yeah this is
the tonight show oh that's interesting i
didn't know that you applied just for
any like a ph position yeah well they
had listings on the website and i don't
think they could put like need a new
assistant for conan because i think it
would they would have just been
inundated so they were just like looking
for production assistance
so i was like all right i'll just you
know was this like on the nbc internal
website or was it just somewhere
yes it was everyone could see okay it
was the internal website and so uh i
wanted to move from the network to
production and i specifically wanted to
work for conan so i i just applied sarah
federovic who's our line producer called
me into and she's like you're actually
going to interview to be cohen's
assistant
and she's like are you okay with that
and i was like i guess yeah i've never
been anyone's personal assistant before
but sure but i've worked at burger king
i could do it but i worked at burger
king
yes
you want pressure try getting an order
out and having someone pay in in under
30 seconds you know
so uh then i interviewed with feds and
then it went from a pool of 10 people to
a pool of four people and then uh the
second interview was with sarah
federovich tracy king and conan and then
i found out like that night that i got
the job wow like it was a really quick
yeah process yeah he he just left i'm
sure they knew as soon as you left the
room right i don't know i mean there
were a lot of like conan thought i was a
really short woman and that i had like
really big curly hair which you know i
do but i think his perception of me was
it was like a cartoon
yeah
and also looking back on it i could see
that he was like thinking about a
million other things too so he was
probably like who is just like who'll
just work and then i think you know they
just chose me boy was he mistaken
right yeah and then they were like you
know what can you commit five years to
this job and i remember thinking five
years who the [ __ ] gonna commit to
being wow and that was 13 years ago wow
today guys today's my first way because
today's armenian christmas armenian
christmas was my first day on the job oh
that's great oh wow cool
yeah
and merry christmas anniversary thank
you thank you thanks guys